So, ist schon irgendjemand da? Mein zweiter Rechner ist gerade abgekackt, wo ich die Stream-Vorschau habe.
Kann mir jemand sagen, ob wir Quality Options haben? Wobei, ich kann einfach nachgucken, ob wir Quality Options haben.
Ah ne, kann ich nicht, weil ich die Tastatur am anderen Rechner stecken habe. Na, auch geil.
Ich werde umstöpseln.
Gucken wir, ob wir Quality Options haben.
Gleich war Ton aus.
Ah, wir haben Quality Options.
Da gesellt sich zu den Broggers ein Poggers.
Quality Options, nice.
So, ich muss mich erstmal wieder auf dem anderen Rechner anmelden.
Ich sehe gerade keinen Chat.
Falls das überhaupt schon alles richtig live ist auf Twitch. Ja, ist es ja.
Ich gucke jetzt mal Chat in der Zeit, bis mein zweiter Rechner gestartet ist.
So, das sieht schon besser aus.
Äh, kann das sein, dass der Sound irgendwie weg ist?
Ah, jetzt.
So, jetzt ist, ja, nice. Jetzt ist der zweite Rechner auch da. Jetzt kann es ja langsam losgehen, ne?
Oh moin, M6 Lubech.
Oder das heißt wahrscheinlich eher M-Blu-Besch.
Gehe ich mal von aus, sondern das 6 ist eher eine B, oder?
Sag mal, kann das sein, dass du mir irgendwie gefühlt jeden zweiten Tag auf Twitter folgst und entfolgst?
Ich habe jetzt den Namen da schon öfters gesehen, weil Twitter ja immer zwischendurch anzeigt, wenn du refreshst, wer folgt und wer nicht folgt.
Und Twitter zeigt mir in letzter Zeit irgendwie immer an, M-Blu-Besch folgt und entfolgt und folgt und entfolgt und folgt.
Erwischt.
Der Sibaro ist auch am Start. Ja, ich habe extra für dich Quality Options angemacht.
Nicht, dass ich da Einfluss drauf hätte.
Telekom hat das Internet gefixt.
Wie fixt denn die Telekom das Internet?
Also bei mir schafft es die Telekom nicht.
Ich habe vor, ich bin jetzt ja letztens erst...
...von Unity Media zur Telekom gewechselt.
Und jetzt überlege ich ernsthaft, weil die Telekom so viele Probleme hat mit allen möglichen Seiten, einfach weil die Verbindung lahm ist dorthin, ja.
Und weil bei mir auch das Sync vom DSL-Modem irgendwie ab und zu mal abreißt, geht mir echt auf den Sack.
Deswegen habe ich mir überlegt, ob ich jetzt nicht wieder von der Telekom nächstes Jahr zu Unity Media wechsle.
Also ich meine, ich bin ja immer noch bei Unity Media, weil ich es kündigen verpasst habe.
Das heißt, ich könnte eigentlich Telekom wieder kündigen und dann Unity Media machen, weil wir haben jetzt bei Unity Media...
...gibt es jetzt was Neues, habe ich gesehen, das ist für mich gut.
Also aktuell kriege ich bei der Telekom VDSL 100 und kann upgraden auf 250.
Das kostet aber mal ordentlich Geld.
So, ich zeige euch das mal.
Das kostet...
Das ist übelst teuer.
Ich zeige euch das mal kurz.
Ja, Unity Media 1 GB.
Geht nicht.
Da wohne ich einen Ticken zu weit weg.
Einen Tick.
Gucken wir mal, ob es da eine Karte gibt.
Ich wohne ja nicht direkt in Frankfurt.
Ich wohne ja ein bisschen neben Frankfurt.
Und es geht nicht so weit.
Also bei der Telekom ist das höchste der Gefühle, was ich kriege aktuell...
Warum müssen diese Seiten eigentlich so übelst unübersichtlich sein?
Kann mir das mal irgendjemand erklären?
Zu Hause.
Internet und DSL, ja.
So, okay.
Also das höchste der Gefühle, was ich kriege ist...
Das da.
So, für 55...
Also aktuell bezahle ich das, 45 Euro.
Und das heißt, dann müsste ich 10 Euro mehr bezahlen bei der Telekom.
So, und da kriege ich max. 250, 40.
Mit dem großen Vorteil, ich kriege einen vollwertigen Dual-Stack-Anschluss.
Das kriegen die hier bei Unity Media nicht hin, weil sie einfach zu wenig IPv4-Adressen haben.
Also bei der Telekom würde ich 250 Down, 40 Up kriegen.
Ein richtiger Dual-Stack.
Mit dem Problem, dass...
Ich muss mir das jetzt mal aufschreiben.
Sonst vergesse ich das nämlich wieder.
Also, Telekom gibt es 250 Down, 40 Up für 55 Euro im Monat.
Das Problem bei der Telekom ist...
Äh, DSL-Sync.
Manchmal weg.
Und das andere Problem bei der Telekom ist...
Äh, Kack-Verbindung.
Zu Twitch.
Twitch, YouTube und andere.
Das ist zwar ganz viel, das ist wirklich ätzend mit der Telekom.
Ich muss manchmal echt umschalten auf Unity Media, dass ich überhaupt manche Sachen angucken kann, wenn viel los ist.
So, das ist Telekom.
So, Unity Media.
Ach so, ja, Moment.
Also das hier ist...
Das hier ist, äh, Con-Telekom.
So, und Pro-Telekom.
Pro-Telekom ist eindeutig...
...richtiger Dual-Stack.
So.
Das, das, da sieht man wieder, was das für eine Scheiße ist.
Das gibt eigentlich nichts richtig Gutes in Deutschland bei mir.
So, und wenn wir jetzt bei Unity Media gucken, ja, nämlich was, was Neues.
Alter, wie mir diese Scheiß...
Oh, die, das auf jeder Seite...
Hat da, hat da nicht schon mal einer einen Browser-Plugin oder so entwickelt?
Was diese komischen Pop-Ups standardmäßig akzeptiert.
Weil ich meine, das ändert doch eh nichts großartig dabei.
Ich block doch eh fast alles noch.
So.
Und bei der Telekom...
Bei Unity Media krieg ich...
Okay, Fairness halber müssen wir das hier vergleichen.
Aber ich brauch ja eh Unity Media für Fernsehstells.
Also nicht für mich, aber ja.
Ist das so?
Ist das halt, ja.
So, ähm...
Ähm...
Ich find das immer geil, ne?
Wie sie hier, wie sie hier oben rumstelzen.
Dabei kostet dich das nur eins von zwei Jahren, wo du gebunden bist.
Also du bist...
Du bist sicher noch ein zweites Jahr dabei, wo du dann das bezahlst.
Ne?
Das ist halt...
Halbe Knackt.
Ach ja, und übrigens, was hier nicht dabei steht, ist...
Ähm...
Genau, das kommt nämlich noch dabei.
Das kommt nämlich noch dabei.
Das darf man nicht vergessen.
Ähm...
Der Kabelanschluss...
Der muss noch dazu bezahlt werden.
Also in Wirklichkeit sind das...
Und jetzt haltet euch mal fest.
Das sind quasi...
Gucken wir mal.
Gut, hier ist es ein bisschen weniger.
Aber ich mein...
Ich brauch ja im Prinzip den Kabelanschluss zum...
Zum Fernseh...
Moment, der ist ja nicht dabei.
Warum ist der Kabelanschluss denn nicht dabei?
So wird er voll behindert.
Was genau ist denn der Vorteil davon jetzt?
Ich mein...
Hä?
Die Preisgestaltung ist komisch.
Kein Kabelanschluss notwendig.
Okay.
Ja, aber ich brauch ja einen Kabelanschluss, damit meine Mutter Fernseh gucken kann.
So...
Ich guck ja keinen Fernseher.
Äh...
Das ist bescheuert.
Ne, der gehört nicht.
Achso, der doch.
Ich muss den dabei bezahlen, weil der Kabelanschluss mir gehört.
Ähm...
Moment, wo ist denn jetzt da der Unterschied?
Kann mir das jetzt mal irgendeiner...
Checkt das irgendeiner?
Also hier brauch ich...
Voraussetzung ist ein Kabelanschluss von Unity Media.
Wenn ich jetzt aber...
Nur mal so, ne?
Hier muss ich den Kabelanschluss dabei bezahlen.
Ja klar, du musst das Unity Media...
Dass du Fernseh gucken kannst mit dem Unity Media Anschluss.
Obwohl der Kabelanschluss im Keller ist, musst du Geld bezahlen.
Da musst du dir diesen Basis-Fernsehtarif holen.
Wie gesagt, ich brauch ja eigentlich keinen Fernseher.
Aber...
Meine Mutter will Fernseh gucken.
Meine Mutter wohnt im Erdgeschoss.
Und die ist da ganz scharf drauf.
Und der gehört letztendlich auch das Haus.
Was wir...
Das hat mir in dem Video, glaube ich, vor ein paar Jahren im Video gezeigt.
Das haben wir ja geerbt.
Beziehungsweise hat sie ja geerbt vom Opa.
Und da haben wir gesagt...
Warum sollten wir den Krams verkaufen?
Wenn man doch ein Haus hat.
Das ist eigentlich irgendwie naheliegend.
Am Anfang wollte ich nicht.
Und dann habe ich gesagt, ey, lass den Scheiß verkaufen.
Ich bleibe in meiner Wohnung.
Aber dann habe ich mir mal Gedanken drüber gemacht.
Dass das so deutlich angenehmer ist.
Erstens die Lage zum Bahnhof ist viel besser.
Und die Nachbarn sind mir in der alten Wohnung übelst auf den Sack gegangen.
Jetzt habt ihr teilweise...
Das kennt ihr doch früher noch aus den Videos, wo die Kinders rumgeschrien haben.
Wo ich Fenster teilweise im Sommer auf habe.
Wo die Kinders unten rumgeschrien haben.
Wo sie dann irgendwie Krankenwagen gespielt haben und ins Haus gerannt sind.
Alter, da gingen die Kinders mir auf den Sack in der alten Wohnung.
Tja.
Da habe ich gedacht, warum nicht?
Ziehen wir ins Haus vom Opa.
So, und zumindest ich habe halt gesagt, ich bezahle das ganze Internetzeug.
Deswegen muss ich jetzt gerade mal gucken.
Also jetzt gehen mir die Nachbarn nicht auf den Sack.
Die Nachbarn sind echt in Ordnung.
Kann ich nicht sagen.
Wir haben einmal als Nachbarn eine türkische Familie.
Mit irgendwie...
Oder fünf Kindern oder so.
Aber die haben die ganz gut im Griff.
Außer, dass die Kleinen ab und zu mal rumschreien.
Passiert da eigentlich nichts.
Und auf der anderen Seite wohnt auch eine Familie mit drei...
Ne, zwei oder drei Kinder.
Ich glaube drei Kinder.
Also die gehen übelst ab.
Die produzieren alle Nachwuchse ohne Ende.
Aber die halten alle die Klappe.
Die sagen nichts.
Weißt du, was ich immer lustig finde teilweise?
Von unseren türkischen Nachbarn.
Du siehst ja doch mal den ein oder anderen auf der Straße.
Und die sind nicht ganz so konservativ.
Da darf die Frau auch alleine raus.
Und es ist aber witzig, wenn du da vorbeiläufst zum Eingang und sagst dann irgendwie Hallo oder sowas.
Die guckt dich nicht an.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das verboten ist, fremde Männer anzugucken.
Oder ob sie Demut zeigen muss.
Keine Ahnung.
Die guckt mich nie an.
Ich sage, ja, hallo, na, vorbei.
Und die sagt dann zwar auch Hallo, aber guckt dann so demonstrativ irgendwo so schräg an einem vorbei.
Ich sage, hä?
Aber gut, Mann.
Wenn das so ist, ne?
Sie wurde wahrscheinlich dementsprechend erzogen, dass ich das so gehört.
Ja, übrigens Fortnite, ne?
Kennt ihr dieses, das ist übelst...
Ich muss mal kurz, warte mal.
Ich such das mal auf Twitter kurz raus.
Aber das mache ich auf einem anderen Rechner.
Weil auf Twitter findet man sonst Dinge, wo man instant gebannt wird, wenn ich das in die Suche eingebe.
Das da, ey.
Alter.
Kinder Schei...
Kinder Kacke, ey.
Wartet mal, guckt euch das mal an, ey.
Von wegen Fortnite.
Fortnite ist das neue Cod, was das angeht.
Achtung.
Alter, die kleinen Bisse.
Ich, okay, ich höre mich übelst kinderfeindlich an, ich weiß, ja.
Aber, Alter, das ist doch nicht normal.
Das ist doch nicht normal.
Oh, das tut weh.
Haha.
Max der Kinderhass war wieder am Start, ey.
Aber ich finde das ist übelst...
Das ist einmal übelst cringe, so übelst Fremdschämen.
Und auf der anderen Seite denke ich mir so, hääh.
Das muss doch sein, ey.
Das ist wirklich komplett rip.
Ey, guckt es euch mal an.
Die sind...
Wie alt sind die, keine Ahnung, irgendwie, äh.
Warum wird das eigentlich größer, wenn man die Seite kleiner macht.
Quick Mafs auf YouTube, guckt mal.
Oh, das ist YouTube Lodi, guckt mal.
Ich mache größer und das Video wird kleiner.
Erst ab 300% wird das Video größer und die Seite, der Hintergrund geht weg, weil YouTube.
So, und das Video, das richtig größer wird das Video nur, wenn ich die Seite kleiner mache.
Ich meine, keine Ahnung, was sind die?
Fünf?
Ja, sind die fünf?
Alter, das ist, oh, das tut weh.
Das schmerzt beim Zugucken.
Das tut echt weh.
So, wir waren bei Internetanbietern.
Bevor wir dann noch ein bisschen Proggers machen noch.
Ja, also, so ganz habe ich das ja nicht verstanden.
Guck mal, das hier kostet 60 Euro im Monat und ich muss noch einen Kabelanschluss dabei bezahlen, was nochmal 20 Euro sind.
Also bezahle ich 80 Euro im Monat für Fernseh-, Internet- und Telefon.
So, wenn ich jetzt 2PlayFly400, auch schon geiler Name, nehme und den normalen Kabelanschluss dabei, dann bezahle ich 70 Euro im Monat.
Warum sollte ich Fly400 nehmen?
Versteht das irgendjemand?
Warum kostet das hier unter dem Strich 10 Euro mehr im Monat als das?
Kann sein, dass der Kabelanschluss über die Mietnebenkosten bezahlt wird.
Nein, wird er nicht.
Also, ich weiß nicht.
Ich bezahle ihn ja, der wird garantiert nicht über die Mietnebenkosten bezahlt.
Außerdem sind wir ja nicht in Miete hier.
Aber ich verstehe das nicht.
Ich meine, guckt mal, im Prinzip, das hier, ne, das hier ist für, das ist ja fake, was hier steht.
Hier müssten, hier müssten, eigentlich müssten hier 80 Euro stehen.
80 Euro für Internet, Fernseh, Telefon.
Und hier, rechnen wir hier das drauf.
Ähm, 70 Euro für Internet, Fernseh, Telefon.
Wo ist der Unterschied?
Warte mal, Details, Details, okay, Details, Details.
Vermiete einfach an dich selber.
Ja, dann kann ich den Kabelanschluss in den Mietnebenkosten bezahlen.
Boah, das ist Big Brain, das ist Massive.
Null.
Bei einem ist kein Fernsehen in HD dabei.
Doch, klar.
Doch.
Das steht hier halt nicht.
Weil hier ist, also, nochmal, zu mitschreiben.
Das hier ist der, das hier ist das Angebot nur Internet und Telefon.
Dazu kann man sich aber den Basisanschluss holen.
Der kostet 20 Euro von Unity Media.
Und da ist halt alle öffentlich-rechtlichen in HD dabei.
Deswegen sind wir hier bei 70 Euro.
Und hier ist quasi das offizielle Fernseh-Internet ohne Horizon.
Ja, wozu brauche ich eine Horizon-Box?
Die wollen ernsthaft 10 Euro im Monat mehr für so eine komische Horizon-Box?
Wozu?
Ich habe überhaupt keine Verwendung für eine Horizon-Box.
Verstehe ich nicht.
Also, das heißt, im Endeffekt, Unity Media kriege ich dann...
Ah, Moment, ich muss noch eine Sache.
Ich muss noch Power-Upload dazu rechnen.
Das kostet natürlich auch Bonus.
Das kostet nochmal 3 Euro im Monat.
Also bezahle ich 73...
73 Euro?
Äh, mit...
Gut, da ist...
Das stimmt nicht.
Hier muss ich das wieder abziehen.
Ich bezahle 53 Euro, weil...
Ähm, unterm Strich...
20 Euro für Kabelanschluss mit, äh...
ZDF, ARD, HD muss ich immer bezahlen.
Egal, ob ich Telekom oder Unity Media nehme.
Immer.
Also.
Also für 53?
Für 53 Euro kriege ich bei Unity Media im Endeffekt...
Ähm...
Mit Power-Upload.
Das ist mit 40.
Da kriege ich dann quasi 400 down und 40 ab.
Was eigentlich viel besser ist.
Das große...
Das Pro bei Unity Media ist allerdings, das ist bei mir...
Das trifft jetzt überhaupt nicht global zu.
Bei mir ist Unity Media viel stabiler als die Telekom.
Ja, ich habe...
Ich war...
Also...
Du kannst...
Man kann mit der...
Mit der Horizon...
Mit der Horizon-Box kann man irgendwie...
Das ist aber hier gar nicht drin, ne?
Wenn man sich das anguckt.
Hier sind auch nur die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen drin, ne?
Ach, ne, doch.
Pro 7 HD.
Ne, das ist Horizon TV.
Hier sind auch nur die Öffentlich-Rechtlichen drin, ne?
Oder?
Ne, das ist hier schon dabei, oder?
In Horizon TV bereits enthalten.
Ah, das bezahlt man hier damit.
Okay.
Ja, aber das Problem ist...
Das Problem dabei ist, ja...
Was die einmal immer nicht erzählen,
dass quasi alles außer...
Das ist auch...
Das ist auch so ein Fail-Gebiet in Deutschland, ey.
Es ist alles außer öffentlich-rechtlichen Fernsehsender
in HD zu empfangen, ist absolut Cancer.
Öffentlich-Rechtliche zu empfangen in HD ist gut,
da ist nichts verschlüsselt oder sonst was.
Aber versucht mal,
was einem da in den Weg gestellt wird,
und das ist aktuell auch gar nicht möglich, so ohne weiteres,
irgendwie bestimmt, ja, aber...
Also, mir ist keine funktionierende Lösung bekannt,
wie man quasi private HD-Sender empfangen kann,
außer mit dem offiziellen Empfänger.
Und ich will das nicht mit dem offiziellen Empfänger machen.
Wenn ich das mit dem offiziellen Empfänger
an einem Fernseher in einem Raum machen will,
das will ich nicht.
Ich will das ganz normal aufnehmen,
auf mein NAS,
und dann im Endeffekt von allen Clients,
die es gibt, gucken können.
Und nicht so einen Scheiß mit der offiziellen Box.
So, also, das heißt,
bei mir ist Unity Media viel stabiler,
und Con, das ist halt relativ big,
ja, das ist
Dual-Stack-Light
und Carrier-Crate-Nut.
Wie kürzt man das eigentlich ab?
CG-Nut? Keine Ahnung.
Dual-Stack
mit Carrier-Nut.
So, das ist, ähm...
Das ist das riesen Con
bei Unity Media.
Man darf ja nicht vergessen, dass immer mehr, so,
Seiten über IPv6 erreichbar sind,
und, jetzt kommt der große Knackpunkt,
im Vergleich zu ein paar Jahren,
ist auch das komplette
Telekom-Mobile-Netz
mittlerweile IPv6.
Das heißt, ich kann ohne Probleme VPN
vom Handy heim machen
über IPv6, und das funktioniert dann.
So.
Das sagt Balls.
Ich hab aktuell Unity Media lang genug
genervt, dass mein Anschluss umgestellt
wurde auf klassisches IPv4,
aber ich geh mal ganz stark
davon aus, wenn ich jetzt hier was umstelle,
upgrade oder sonst was,
stellen die den Shit wieder um.
Garantiert.
Weil die haben einfach nicht genug Adressen.
Äh, kannst du die Cons für Noobs erklären?
War's das da?
Dual-Stack-Light-Carrier-Nut?
Oder, oder die...
Na, die Cons sind... Also, okay, du meinst die
Unity Media-Cons. Mach ich. Kann ich dir erklären.
Ähm...
Kannst du nicht über Business-Anschluss nen IPv4
bekommen? Doch, Sebaro, kann ich.
Die Sache ist die,
dort ist, ähm...
Ich überleg grad, wie das war.
Genau, dort gibt es kein,
kein Fernsehzeug. Also du musst,
du musst bei Business quasi
viele Sachen nochmal zusätzlich bezahlen.
Aber gucken wir mal.
Falls ich's vergesse, ähm,
erinner mich gleich nochmal dran, ähm,
Undisputed, ich erklär das gleich nochmal, was das ist.
Weil hier gibt's ja im Endeffekt nur,
äh,
Office, Internet und Phone.
Gibt's hier auch, gibt's hier auch den
Power-Upload dabei.
Guck mal, hier bezahl ich quasi 70.
Und da müsste ich dann nochmal
den Kabelanschluss
dabei rechnen, äh, wir rechnen jetzt hier
Power-Upload dabei.
Äh, da bin ich ja, so viel teurer
ist das im Prinzip gar nicht, ne.
Die Frage ist, ist das, ist das
noch, ist das noch ne statische,
statische IPv4?
Das wäre tatsächlich ne
Option, dann würde ich halt
85 Euro im Monat bezahlen.
Also im Prinzip nur 5 Euro
mehr. Ich mein, es
kostet, es kostet 20 Euro
mehr als das normale, ne.
Ne, 10 Euro.
Ne, äh,
Power-Upload dabei. 15.
15 Euro mehr als das normale.
Ja, ich mein, das sind halt 15
Euro im Monat. Ich mein, aber an sich, an sich, äh,
an sich ist das tatsächlich ne Überlegung
wert, dass ich mir nen Basiskabelanschluss
lasse und, ähm,
dann das, das
müssen, dass ich Unity-Media hole, sofern's da
Power-Upload gibt.
Geht's da Power, Power
Upload? Weil
20 hab ich, 20, äh, wenn schon
will ich 40, jetzt hab ich mich auch an 40 gewöhnt.
Jetzt Power-Upload.
Privatkunden. Tja, da weiß man nicht,
ob das da funktioniert.
Da muss ich mal bei Unity-Media anrufen, aber
ansonsten, ansonsten wär das ne Option.
So.
Also, ich wollte DSDS Lite erklären.
Ähm, ja,
Power-Upload, das heißt halt bei denen so,
ich find's genau so bescheuert.
Power-Upload, ne? Ist ja nicht so, als
könnte man das nicht ohne Probleme machen. Dieses,
dass das, es ist eh
ein bisschen lächerlich, dass sich das etabliert hat,
dass die Dinger so krass asynchron sind,
ne? Das ging ja teilweise bis
irgendwie, ähm,
410 ab und so.
Da ist ja das, da wird das A
in, in, in, in ADSL
von asynchron zu ASI-DSL,
ey, jetzt 410.
Ja, in der Schweiz, du kannst auch
in Südkorea gucken, in Südkorea haben sie das auch.
So, aber ich wollte erklären, was
DSLite ist. Also, ähm,
bei Unity-Media haben sie anscheinend nicht genug
IPv4-Adressen.
Die Telekom anscheinend schon.
Deswegen müssen sie sich
irgendwas einfallen lassen.
Ähm, also man muss sich
vorstellen, es gibt viele Seiten, die sind mittlerweile
über IPv6 erreichbar, allerdings
viele Seiten sind auch nicht
über IPv4, äh, über IPv6
erreichbar. Deswegen kann sich das
ein Provider nicht leisten,
einfach zu sagen,
drauf geschissen, das IPv4
Internet kannst du nicht,
kannst du nicht drauf zugreifen.
Das kannst du vergessen. Den, den nimmt keiner
und vor allem nicht technisch
versierte Leute verstehen das nicht.
Die checken das auch nicht.
Wie willst du das denen erklären, ja?
Ich übervorstelle irgendwie, was soll's ich, ähm,
irgendeine Oma will, äh,
was gibt's denn da, so Musikanten-Stadel-Seite
aufmachen und die ist nicht über
IPv6 erreichbar.
Und die geht nicht, dann ruft sie bei
Unity Media an und da muss der Unity Media
erklären, dass sie nur IPv6 hat und
kein IPv4 und Musikanten-Stadel nur über
IPv4 geht und das
checkt die nicht. Ich wusste gar nicht, dass
Twitter auch nur v4-only ist.
So, zumindest
deswegen
sehen wir schon mal, Unity Media kann sich
das nicht leisten, IPv4 außen vor zu lassen.
Problem ist allerdings, sie
haben nicht, ähm,
ich weiß gar nicht, ob das hier mit lite dabei steht,
ne, hehehe
Dual-Stack-Line, das haben sie erst gar nicht hingeschrieben,
glaube ich. So, und
nachdem sie nicht genug IPv4-Adressen
zur Verfügung haben, aber die Leute
quasi ans IPv4-Internet
anbinden müssen, was ja erstmal irgendwie ein Widerspruch
ist, ja, greifen sie zu
einem Trick. Und dieser Trick
nennt sich DASlide
mit Carrier-Grade-Nut. Das
bedeutet, DS steht für
Dual-Stack. Dual-Stack heißt normalerweise
und die Telekom
macht richtig in Dual-Stack, Dual-Stack bedeutet
normalerweise, du kriegst eine IPv4-
Adresse und eine IPv6-Adresse.
Und dann kannst du, machst du
eine DNS-Auflösung und guckst,
ob der Dienst, wo du drauf zugreifen
willst, über IPv4 oder IPv6
erreichbar ist. Das siehst du anhand der DNS-
Antwort. Und dann gehst
du einfach dorthin, wo es dir
danach ist, beziehungsweise wo da
in Windows die Prioritäten liegen.
Ich gehe mal davon aus, Windows wird IPv6
bevorzugen, wenn beides zur Verfügung
steht. Geht, überhaupt kein Problem.
Mit richtigem Dual-Stack.
Weil Dual-Stack lite,
ist das jetzt anders.
Du bekommst keine IPv4-Adresse
mehr. Du bekommst nur noch
eine, also du bekommst
keine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse
mehr, wie bei der Telekom.
Das heißt, du bekommst nur noch
eine IPv6-Adresse
und
ich vermute mal eine private
IPv4-Adresse.
Und das
wird getunnelt, quasi
von dir, zu
Unity Media. Das kann auch sein,
dass du nur eine IPv6
kriegst.
Weil 6 auf 4
ist kein Problem. 4 auf 6 geht nicht
gescheit.
Ich weiß nicht ganz
genau im Detail. Jetzt müssen wir mal gucken, wie es funktioniert.
Zumindest du kriegst keine öffentliche IPv4-Adresse
mehr bei Dual-Stack lite.
Du kriegst quasi,
sagen wir mal, nur noch eine öffentliche
IPv6-Adresse und dein
IPv4-Traffic wird getunnelt
über einen IPv6-Tunnel.
Also sprich,
so wie das kleine Rotti gerade geschrieben hat,
dein IPv4-Traffic
läuft über eine IPv6-
Verbindung zu Unity Media, also über
einen Tunnel, weil der Endpunkt muss ja wissen,
was er damit machen muss.
Und jetzt
kommen wir zu CarrierCrateNut.
Nachdem jetzt ja dein IPv4-Traffic
über den IPv6-Tunnel
bei Unity Media
rauskommt, müssen
die irgendwie dafür sorgen, dass du
jetzt weitergeleitet wirst in das
IPv4-Internet.
Nachdem sie aber zu wenig
IPv4-Adressen haben,
das haben wir ja immer noch nicht gelöst,
aktuell tunneln sie dich nur über IPv6,
machen sie
CarrierCrateNut, dass da Carrier davor steht,
ist im Prinzip egal, das ist das gleiche wie Nut daheim.
Nut bedeutet in dem Fall,
du teilst dir dann mit mehreren
Kunden auf einem Ausgangspunkt
eine öffentliche
IPv4-Adresse.
Also sprich, der Weg ist von dir IPv4-Traffic
durch den IPv6-Tunnel
zu Unity Media, dort
über einen Ausgang
genuttet, wo mehrere
Leute verwenden.
Das sorgt für zig Probleme
bei IPv4-Verbindungen.
So Sachen wie
Xbox-Lobbys funktionieren nicht richtig,
kann man nichts richtig dagegen machen,
du hast auch keine Chance
beispielsweise in Black Ops
eine Lobby aufzumachen im Neuen,
das ist ja immer noch Peer-to-Peer-hosting.
Wobei ich weiß gar nicht, ob das mittlerweile über
IPv6 gescheit funktioniert.
Evolv ist manchmal problematisch,
VPN ist problematisch,
also das ist wirklich
die absolute Krücke, das Ding, dass das überhaupt
funktioniert.
Und ja, das ist
DSLine und Carrier Credit.
Also das ist richtige, richtige
Krücke, dass das funktioniert.
Das heißt, die Option
einen
Unity Media Anschluss zu buchen,
einen Unity Media Business Anschluss,
da hast du wieder das Problem, Business hat anscheinend
keinen Power-Upload.
Ich will 40 MBit Upload haben.
Ich kann Business nicht schreiben, wie schreibt man Business?
Das ist so ein Wort, ich schreibe es
aus Prinzip immer falsch.
Wo schreibt man das? Fast richtig.
Undisputed
tatsächlich
kann er nicht.
Allerdings wird Unity Media wissen
oder aufzeichnen, wie welche
Verbindung gelaufen ist bei ihnen.
Aber prinzipiell
sieht dein Gegenüber
nicht mehr deine öffentliche IPv4
Adresse, sondern die öffentliche
IPv4 Adresse, die
bei Unity Media ganz viele Leute verwenden.
Deswegen übrigens bekommt man
sau oft das Google Captcha.
Kennt ihr das Google Suche Captcha?
Das kommt
immer, wenn man zu viel
Suchanfragen verursacht und
Google denkt, du bist ein Bot.
Das hast du laufend über Unity Media.
IPv4, wenn du es bei IPv4
verwendest, hast du das laufend bei Unity Media.
Weil halt die Absender IP
von, keine Ahnung, ich weiß nicht wie viele Leute
so einen Ausgang verwenden, ich sag jetzt einfach mal 100,
ja.
Ein Vorteil ist
dann doch mehr Sicherheit im Netz.
Naja, eigentlich nicht, weil du hast ja bei
IPv4 bei dir daheim auch nochmal NAT davor.
Das heißt du hast doppel NAT.
Im Endeffekt, also hättest
du, wenn du was dazwischen hast.
Was die ganze Sache noch schlimmer macht.
Und ein
riesiger Nachteil davon ist,
darf man nicht vergessen,
das liest sich jetzt erstmal so, ah gut,
kann man damit leben, es gehen
keine Port
Forwarding.
Weil, ist ja ganz logisch, wenn Port Forward
bedeutet, von der öffentlichen
IP, die auf deinem Router liegt,
oder wie die Cisco Leute gerne sagen, auf deinem Router,
dort sagst
du, Port XY wird auf die interne
IP
1 weitergeleitet.
Das geht ja damit
nicht. Weil,
die Verbindungen, die zu dir wollen, bleiben
schon mal im Carrier-Knet-Nut hängen.
Und Unity Media wird mir bestimmt nicht
erlauben, auf ihre Router drauf zu gehen, ohne
Port Weiterleitung einzurichten für mich.
Ein Router, genau.
Ein Router.
Ja, das stimmt, also für die meisten
Nutzer, da muss ich TiraVox recht geben,
für die meisten Nutzer, die merken das wahrscheinlich
nicht. Leute, die ein bisschen basteln wollen,
die quasi irgendwie
VPN
heim aufmachen wollen, die irgendwie
ihre Nextcloud in der Reverse-Proxy
daheim stehen haben, oder irgendwie sowas,
und wo es nicht möglich ist, überhaupt IPv6
zuzugreifen, die werden das merken.
Mittlerweile
der Grund, warum ich es damals unbedingt haben
wollte, noch IPv4 für meinen Unity Media
Anschluss, war unabhängig
von den Problemen, die ich
hatte.
Ich überlege gerade, was das
hauptsächliche Problem war, was nicht funktioniert hat.
Ich habe zumindest
Unity Media übelst geflamed auf Twitter, das weiß ich
noch.
Gucken wir doch mal, was ich da geschrieben habe.
Da sehen wir auch wieder, was ich
für Probleme hatte. Aber das Problem
also das IPv6 aus
dem Mobile-Netz-Problem gibt es nicht
mehr.
Ich weiß gar nicht mehr, was ich denn
geschrieben habe. Zumindest hatte ich irgendwelche Probleme,
was mir...
Habe ich irgendwas an den Lost geschrieben?
Wenn alles so bleibt, bin ich mit der Lösung
von Unity Media zufrieden. So, jetzt ist noch die Frage, was ich
für ein Problem hatte.
Aktuell funktioniert nun alles, super Sache.
Das ist ja schön, Max, dass alles
funktioniert, aber was war denn das Problem?
Ah.
Außer, dass ich Unity Media lobe, sehe ich
da jetzt nichts.
Ah, ja, die YouTube-Uploads waren am Arsch.
Stimmt, das war mein
Problem damals, genau.
YouTube über IPv4, was damals
noch nicht richtig über IPv6 funktioniert hat,
ähm,
war IPv4-Traffic
per Kilobyte. Übelst lahm.
Das war das Problem
damals. Da habe ich gesagt, Unity Media,
ich habe mal euren Anschluss nur geholt,
weil ihr mehr uploadt als die anderen
habt und was ich damit machen will, ist YouTube-Videos
hochladen und bei euch noch beschissener.
Ja, und da haben sie sich
relativ
schnell drum gekümmert.
Also schnell ist, äh,
die Sache, was?
21. Januar habe ich das gepostet.
21. Januar
und die Sache
gegessen war...
Ah, siehst du, das hat doch eine ganze Weile gedauert.
Das hat doch, also die haben auch schon irgendwie
3 Wochen oder so gebraucht. Da habe ich dann immer umgeschaltet,
wieder auf die Telekom. Richtig Fail.
So, und das ist halt
das Problem gewesen. Aber ich, ich
denke mal,
ich denke mal, das ist mittlerweile behoben.
Wenn nicht, wenn nicht,
das wäre halt echt das Problem, ne?
Wenn nicht, brauche ich wieder 2 Anschlüsse parallel
und das geht mir halt auf den Sack. Ich bezahle so viel Geld
für Internetanschlüsse,
die ich eigentlich gar nicht brauche. Nur
für den Fall der Fälle.
Ja. Telekom habe ich jetzt
für upload, weil es über Unity Media zu langsam ist.
Wenn Telekom rumspackt, habe ich
Unity Media.
Am liebsten hätte ich nur noch Unity Media.
Da würde ich die Festnetztelefonnummern portieren
lassen auf Unity Media
und nachdem jetzt Telekom im Endeffekt auch nur noch
VoIP ist,
nur noch Unity Media
Telekom weg.
Das wäre mir eigentlich am liebsten. Aber sobald du wieder Probleme
mit Unity Media hast oder irgendwas nicht funktioniert
oder der Upload lahm ist, da musst
du dich wochenlang mit denen rumzackern.
Das heißt, wahrscheinlich ist die beste Lösung wirklich
ne
Unity Media Business Anschluss und gucken
ob es
Power Upload gibt.
Unity Media Business mit
40 Mbit Upload wäre doch
ganz gut. Dann würde ich halt
dann würde ich immer noch weniger bezahlen als jetzt mit 2 Anschlüssen.
Ja. Dann würde ich dann irgendwie
89 Euro bezahlen im Monat für
Unity Media
Business mit
Basiskabelanschluss.
Ja.
Ach, gibt es nicht?
Gibt keinen Power Upload für Unity Media. Siehste,
das macht schon mal wieder scheiße.
Und was
Schlussfolgerung wir daraus?
Es gibt einfach keine gute Lösung
für Internet in Deutschland.
Das ist so für'n Arsch.
Das ist nicht einfach,
dass du dir um so viel Scheiße Gedanken machen musst.
Weißt du?
Richtig reudig alles.
Läuft P2P File-Sharing also torrent
über Unity Media bestimmt nicht.
Ich kann mir nicht vorstellen,
dass torrent
ordentlich über
dualstack lite läuft.
Genauso wie was
gab es früher noch? Idunkey und sowas.
Das läuft wahrscheinlich auch nicht.
Könntest du
nicht VPN benutzen über den
Unity Media Anschluss und dann darüber
Port Forwarding machen?
Äh.
Wenn ich VPN über den Unity Media Anschluss
benutze, heißt das ja schon, ich prabe auf beiden Seiten
IPv6.
Und wenn ich auf beiden Seiten schon IPv6 habe,
dann brauche ich auch keine Portweiterleitung mehr,
weil da kann ich direkt drauf zugreifen.
Es besteht die Möglichkeit,
sich selbst einen Tunnel zu bauen.
Wenn man einen Server im Internet hat,
kann man selbst einen Tunnel,
also quasi einen IPv4 über 6 Tunnel bauen.
Das habe ich damals auch mal
kurz gemacht, das war auch nicht gerade schön.
Aber wenn du eh schon
IPv6 auf beiden Seiten hast, brauchst du
ja keinen Tunnel mehr.
Nextcloud selbst
hosten und über
VPN zugreifen oder Server anmieten
und darauf Nextcloud hosten in Bezug auf
Sicherheit und Machbarkeit bei DSLite.
Ich würde Nextcloud immer auf einem Server
bei mir daheim hosten. Immer.
Weil da legst du ja privates Zeug drauf.
Das würde ich nicht irgendwie unverschlüsselt
extern rumliegen lassen oder selbst
verschlüsselt. Also ich würde mein Zeug
nicht extern hinstellen, wenn ich genug Bandbreite
daheim hätte. Und
über DSLite zugreifen ist
denke ich mal
in den meisten Fällen heute kein Problem mehr.
Es geht über DSLite zugreifen besser
als über, also ist, nein Schwachsinn.
Es geht über IPv6 auf jeden Fall besser
als über irgendwelche
NAT-Geschichten und DSLite, wenn du
direkt IPv6 auf beiden Seiten hast.
Ich würde
bloß zwischen Internet und
Nextcloud irgendeine Universe-Proxy
stellen, der dann nochmal zusätzliche
Authentifizierung macht. Am besten 2-Faktor
Authentifizierung
und erst danach dich auf die Nextcloud lässt.
Was zahlst du aktuell
monatlich? Ha!
Ähm
Also, muss ich mal überlegen, irgendwie
irgendwie 60 Euro
Unity Media
sag ich euch, äh
ähm
wie viel hat das Telekom-Ding gekostet?
Das da?
110 Euro müsste ich bezahlen im Monat
aktuell. Deswegen will ich ja auch weg von diesem
doppelten
Internet-Kack.
Also, Unity Media war ja
ist ja schon mehr oder weniger gekündigt.
Allerdings überlege ich jetzt
gerade es umgedreht zu machen, Telekom wieder
zu kündigen und komplett auf Unity Media zu gehen.
Und dann, wisst ihr was ich
dann mach? Dann leg ich mir einfach als
Backup daheim irgendeinen LTE-Stick hin oder so.
Wenn es wirklich mal abkacken gar nicht
mehr geht, weil ohne Internet kann ich halt nicht
leben, das funktioniert nicht,
dann mach ich, äh
mach ich, äh,
LTE oder so.
Tira Fox, was meinst du
viele Jahrzehnte noch
bis in Deutschland mal was ändert? Na, angeblich
angeblich
ja doch bis Ende 2018, ja.
Angeblich
bis Ende 2018.
Ich zeig euch das mal.
Hab ich das falsch geschrieben?
Regierungssprecher.
Oh ja.
Wo hab ich das denn hier geschrieben? Magst du Regierungssprecher?
Äh
Da!
Haben sie doch geschrieben, guck mal!
Haben sie letztes Jahr geschrieben,
am 20. Juni haben sie
geschrieben, 50 MBit für jeden Haushalt
werden wir 2018 schaffen,
aber inzwischen müssen wir in Gigabit denken.
Äh, das ist im Prinzip
der Regierungssprecher Twitter-Account
versucht wahrscheinlich den Rekord zu brechen,
wie viel Scheiße man in 240 Zeichen
schreiben kann. Ansonsten
realistisch gesehen glaube ich nicht,
dass wir es
in naher Zukunft,
also damit meine ich in den nächsten
sagen wir mal
20 Jahre, schaffen werden
irgendwie internettechnisch aufzuholen an den Rest
der Welt um uns drum herum.
Wenn wir, wir können uns
glücklich schätzen,
wenn wir es schaffen nicht noch weiter
zurückzufallen. Weil ich sehe
nicht, dass hier irgendwie Weichen gestellt
werden für
das Internet in Zukunft.
Andere Länder kriegen das hin.
Südkorea hat glaube ich ungefähr
die Hälfte der Heimwohner von Deutschland
und ist irgendwie nur, ist irgendwie
halb so groß oder
ein Drittel so groß oder so, nur
bei denen funktioniert das wunderbar.
Du hast ISDN?
Das glaube ich dir nicht, Sibaro. Ernsthaft?
Gibt es bei euch nichts anderes?
Das ist ja eigentlich laut dem Regierungssprecher
bis Ende 2018 gar nicht möglich.
Was ich auch geil finde, jedes Mal bei der
Overwatch League, ne, die Werbung
von der Telekom, Americas Fastest Unlimited
Network, da denke ich mir immer,
was ist denn das?
Wenn ihr das mal daheim auch hinkriegen würdet.
Ja, in Dänemark, ich glaube
es war in Dänemark, da haben die das, ich bin mir nicht sehr
also nagelt mich jetzt nicht drauf fest, ob es Dänemark war,
aber ich glaube es war Dänemark,
da hatten die wohl auch Probleme,
es könnte auch ein anderes skandinavisches Land gewesen sein,
da hatten die auch Probleme
mit
ihren Internetanbietern, dass sie
quasi nicht das gemacht haben, was die Leute wollten
oder nicht so richtig das gemacht haben, was die Regierung
wollten. Wahrscheinlich wollte da die Regierung
ausnahmsweise mal das, was auch die Leute wollten.
Und da haben sie es so gemacht,
um da ein bisschen Druck aufzubauen,
haben sie olle Funkmasten gekauft
und überall hingestellt und haben quasi super
billig Basic Internet
angeboten, für jeden saumäßig
günstig, ich glaube das war es Dänemark gewesen.
Sprich, dass jeder ziemlich
billig, halt jetzt nicht gerade das
Beste und auch über Funk, Internet
kriegen konnte und haben halt so dann die
Internetanbieter
mehr oder weniger dazu gezwungen, quasi
Besseres anzubieten, weil sie
halt nicht konkurrieren konnten mit den
staatlichen Funkmasten.
Das war halt eine nice Idee, ne?
Die mussten dann quasi
aufrüsten, weil ansonsten hätte die Oma
gesagt, ja Moment, warum soll ich denn hier bei
bei euch irgendwie
80 Kronen, was Kronen haben die in Dänemark
oder haben die auch Euro, ach was weiß ich,
bezahlen und
wenn ich es hier vom Funkmasten um
die Ecke für 25 kriege, warum soll ich das machen?
Ja, das heißt die einzigen Verkaufsargumente,
die die doch hatten, war,
ihr Zeug besser zu machen.
Oder billiger.
Dänische Kronen.
So, eigentlich wollte ich heute noch ein bisschen
Progras machen, aber es ist schon 21
und 2, also im Prinzip
ist der Progras das, wo
wir stehen geblieben sind das letzte Mal.
Progras animiert den Papagei
mit 25,
26 FPS. Ich hab's
jetzt nur noch ein bisschen
geändert hier unten.
Kann ich so,
ich mach eins kleiner, so ist es okay.
So ist zu klein, so ist gut.
Ich glaub so hatten wir's die ganze Zeit.
Ich hab das ein bisschen
kleiner gemacht, bisschen einfacher mit dem Timer
hier von gestern und
hab hier ein bisschen das Zeug
ausgelagert in extra Methoden,
dass das ein bisschen einfacher
ist. Ich hab eingebaut, dass man resizen
kann, was ja gestern noch nicht funktioniert
hat. Guckt, man kann jetzt resizen.
Allerdings, ihr seht schon, das Resize
ruckelt. Das Resize ruckelt,
weil ich quasi halt
meine Rendersache quasi weighted
und 25 FPS
ist halt nur, ruckelt halt.
Aber man sieht schon,
aspektmäßig resizen funktioniert
auch. Ist eigentlich ganz
nice.
Dieses hässliche Rectangle muss
ich auch noch anpassen. Ich würd sagen,
wir machen als erstes jetzt nochmal schnell das
Resizen Smo-
Smooser. Weil, wenn man das
Ganze jetzt zum Beispiel mit 12 FPS macht,
wir haben ja auch andere GIFs, die sind nur 12 FPS,
da ist das Resizen,
guckt's mal an hier, das ist schon
ne, ziemlich
geruckelt.
Seht ihr's? Das
Resize ist halt, die Schleife
läuft schon immer 12 Mal in der Sekunde.
Deswegen machen wir das jetzt so,
hab ich mir schon überlegt, das dürfte relativ
einfach sein. Wir machen hier kein,
wir machen hier kein Sleep drum
herum.
Wir machen das, also aktuell machen
wir's da so, so die Billig-Variante.
Wir lassen die Schleife einmal durchlaufen
und dann warten wir hier
die Zeit bis zur, bis zum nächsten Frame
und dann machen wir wieder
den Durchlauf. Das heißt, wir machen hier
im Endeffekt nur ein If draus.
Also wir machen die Schleife
weg und machen
das nächste Frame getten
oder das nächste Frame taken
machen wir einfach hier rein
und dann
muss ich glaub ich noch meinen Timer
da rein verlagern
und dann sollte das schon funktionieren.
Und das breaken
muss raus.
Ja guck, jetzt ist
super schmus hier das Resizen.
Super schmus
das Resizen.
Und auch keine
Memory Leaks, ja.
Wir können übrigens noch eine Sache machen.
Ich will mal was gucken.
Ich hab hier das höchste,
das höchste Scaling.
Also was die meiste
Rechenleistung frisst.
Ja, ist ein Ticken schneller,
aber das hält schon Grenzen. Ja machen.
Beste, beste Scaling Options.
Ja, wir haben nicht nur
wir haben nicht nur einfach FPS, wir haben
FPS pro Sekunde.
Moment mal,
diese FPSs hier, ne.
Also das kriegen, das würden wir auch
theoretisch eine ganze Ecke schneller hinkriegen.
Aber
also wenn wir den, ich glaube
wenn wir den
den Decoder ein bisschen mehr
Images cachen lassen, wobei, ne das ist eigentlich egal.
Ne, ich glaub viel schneller kriegen wir es nicht hin.
Aber es ist ja nicht so, als ist das jetzt hier ein Problem.
Ne.
Das ist schon okay.
Schneller lohnt nicht. Ja, seh ich auch.
Seh ich auch. So, das ist wirklich sehr, sehr
nice schon, ja.
Ich mein im Prinzip, er muss ja auch ein bisschen hier was machen.
Er muss ja mindestens einmal quasi
also im Vergleich zu irgendwelchen
Games zum, ne, wenn man jetzt irgendwelche
Games hat, da kopierste halt nicht
unbedingt pro
pro Durchlauf quasi
irgendwelche Dinger
aus dem RAM wieder in die
Grafikkarte und umgedreht. Und so.
Ich mein wozu?
Das hier, das dauert wahrscheinlich auch
kurz, denke ich mal.
Ähm, und ja hier
die Draw-Geschichten werden auch kurz dauern.
Aber ansonsten ist hier halt nichts
dabei, was irgendwie sonderlich lange dauert.
Wir könnten das Disposen
quasi nur einmal machen,
wenn wir auch ein Bild haben.
Bringt ein bisschen was, guckt.
Aber nicht viel.
Übrigens, ist euch aufgefallen,
ich hab das Problem gefixt,
dass der im Debug-Mode abkackt.
Gestern hatten wir doch das Problem,
dass wenn ich Debugger dran hatte,
dass es abgekackt ist.
Und ähm, es sah zwar
im Stream so aus, als haben wir es gefixt, aber
es war nicht wirklich weg.
Wir waren einfach zu langsam, als dass wir es
gemerkt hätten.
Ich hab's gefixt, und zwar
im Decoder
mach ich's jetzt so, ich
ähm, mach das hier mit
Pointer-Action, also
ich mach kein Frame und schreib
den Frame in die Liste und sonst was,
kein Frame-Objekt, ich mach nur einen Pointer
zu einem Frame und schreib auch nur den
nur den Pointer für den
Frame quasi in meine Frame-Klasse
und dann passt das.
Ja. Ja gut,
CPU braucht das Ding immer noch ordentlich,
weil das läuft ja ordentlich,
das läuft ja krass, ne?
Das ist hier am, wir machen jetzt
nochmal V-Sync-Angleich,
das ist ja komplett am rotieren, ne?
Übrigens, wir sind auch
auf 89 MB runter.
Also 89 MB ist absolut top,
da kann sich keiner beschweren für.
Es ist instant da, es ist sauschnell,
das Ding rödelt halt hier im Hintergrund, ne?
Wenn man das jetzt zum Beispiel
sleepen lassen,
wenn wir das jetzt irgendwie nochmal sleepen lassen,
dann sehen wir auch gleich, dass die CPU-Last
halt übel schnell runter geht.
Guck, jetzt haben wir kaum, jetzt haben wir kaum CPU
noch. Gar nichts mehr an CPU.
Aber ist ja auch klar, wir machen ja auch
nix mehr. So,
wir machen V-Sync an, ich muss mal gucken, wo man das
macht, wahrscheinlich in den Swap-Chain-Options, ne?
Ach, übrigens, wir müssen Debug
nochmal ausschalten.
Debug auf dem DirectX-Device, da geht's
noch ein Ticken schneller.
Ja, guckt mal hier.
Guckt mal. Ich wollt grad sagen, warum ist das so langsam.
Guckt mal.
4500 FPS
für den Papagei.
Und ein bisschen, ein bisschen scalen
müssen wir noch, dass das, ich hätt am liebsten,
dass das quasi in die Mitte scaled, wenn ich das Fenster
so, so, so scale.
Wisst ihr?
Ich, ich, ich Memory leake nix.
Das sieht nur so aus, guckt mal.
Der, der,
der macht einfach nur seinen Cache voll.
Das bleibt jetzt, das geht, das geht nicht,
nicht, nicht mehr wirklich hoch.
Also, da muss man sich schon sehr anstrengen, dass es jetzt noch irgendwie
hochgeht. Also, da liegt nix.
Free DirectX
eigentlich die Ressourcen nehmen, musst du alles selbst machen.
Und wie
das auf der Grafikkarte läuft, keine Ahnung.
Äh, wie macht man denn,
wie macht man da
Vsync an?
Bei, bei einem reinen, äh, Direct2D
Device wüsste ich, wie das geht.
Da müssen wir mal Google befragen,
würd ich sagen.
Present Interval. Moment,
DirectX 9, nein, nein, nein, wir müssen mal, wir müssen
11 suchen.
Wir machen das ja, wir sind ja, wir sind ja modern.
Ja, Noah,
geh ich von aus.
Ja, wie man Dis, wie man Vsync Disable ist auch
okay, da kann man ja gucken, wenn man das umgedrehte,
dann enablen wir das einfach.
Was hat denn der Typ da für Zeug?
Ich hätte das eigentlich erwartet, dass man das irgendwie
in der, in der Swap Chain als, als Options,
als Option angibt.
Aber hier haben wir alle Options drinnen,
mehr, ah, Flags, Flags, gibt's da vielleicht was?
Swap Chain Flags?
Ah, da gibt's
bestimmt irgendwas.
Mode Switch, Tiering, Display Only,
Forecounter,
Fullscreen, äh, none, none,
Restricted, jup, nö, gibt's nicht.
Was Buffer, Description,
Refresh Rate, Numerator,
gibt die Nummer, wat?
Wo?
Aber hier kann ich grad nix anfangen.
Laut Tiering ist doch das Gegenteil von,
von Vsync, ja quasi,
ist da was dran.
Kann man hier vielleicht irgendwas, Swap Effect?
In der Swap Chain Description?
Buffer Description,
sowas hab ich ja noch gar nicht.
Ich hab Buffer Count?
Also mir, ich hab ja keine Optionen,
ich hab ja alles gesetzt, ich kann bloß auf Flags setzen.
Oder aber,
muss ich
Swap Chain
Description?
Buffer Count?
Nö.
Ja das ist Swap Chain,
aber ich kann ja,
ich kann ja wahrscheinlich hier auf Description 1 zugreifen,
oder geht das nicht, müssen wir mal ausprobieren.
So und da drinnen
ist es jetzt was?
Swap Effect, ne.
Buffer Count?
Ah!
Im Present.
Das kann natürlich sein,
dass wir es im Present machen müssen
für, für, für Wiese.
Ja.
Auf was stellen wir es jetzt?
Allowed Hearing.
Oh, das funktioniert nicht.
Dann kackts ab.
Was muss man denn hier stellen?
Do, do,
Do not wait ist ja wahrscheinlich das,
was wir jetzt haben.
Außer, dass es, äh,
rippt.
Used to race. Ich hab keine Ahnung, was man das aufstellen muss.
Mach einfach die 0 zur 1.
Ich muss dann den Inum reinhauen.
Was ist denn,
was ist denn hier die 1 drinne?
Ich mein, ich kann, ich kann das casten.
Ach ja, test.
Test?
Herzhaft?
Ne.
Lull.
Ach, der erste Parameter.
Sync Interface. Sag das doch.
Ah, ein nicer V-Sync.
Guck mal, wir sind sogar besser als mein V-Sync.
Wir sind sogar, anstatt
144, sind wir 145.
Aber auch nur manchmal.
Der erste Parameter.
Jaja, ich hab's, ich hab's jetzt gesehen.
Was hast du für eine Visual Studio Version?
Die neueste.
Was denkst du hier?
15.88.
Es gibt jetzt eine neue.
Es gibt, es gibt, äh, übrigens schon Pläne für,
hab ich letztens gelesen,
2019.
Gibt's jetzt, sollte auch irgendwo
ein Preview dazu kommen demnächst.
Und was mich übelst geschockt hat,
ist, was ich gesehen hab,
was Microsoft angekündigt hat, ist
Office 2019.
Ich hab gedacht, wir sind's endlich los, ja.
Die lassen jetzt für immer ihr 360-Kram
und man hat seine Ruhe mit.
Aber nein, es gibt wieder eine neue Offline-Office-Version.
Das wird wieder viele Leute, viele graue Haare bringen, ja.
Ich, wie gesagt, ich benutze ja schon seit Jahren kein Office mehr.
Ich brauch für nichts Office.
Ja.
Ich kann verstehen, wenn, ähm,
sagen wir mal so, der normale User für irgendwie sein, sein, sein Zeug
ein bisschen Office braucht.
Ich, ich bin der Ansicht von Office das einzig, das einzige,
ähm,
was Office wirklich,
wie soll ich sagen, also,
das einzige Office-Programm,
was seine Daseinsberechtigung hat,
ist meiner Ansicht nach Excel.
Ja.
Also wie viele Hobby-Anwendungen quasi in Excel programmiert sind,
will ich gar nicht, will ich gar nichts wissen.
Ähm, aber ansonsten die ganzen anderen Krempeln,
was ist, was ist denn eigentlich so ein Office dabei?
Zeig mal her.
Was, was ist denn da standardmäßig dabei?
Was gibt's denn da alles so?
Get things done mit Office, mit, ich krieg mit Office nix done.
Was haben wir denn da so alles drinne?
Zeig mal her.
Die schreiben doch nicht mal hin, was es gibt, oder?
Ich will doch einfach nur wissen, ah, okay.
Word, Excel, PowerPoint, OneNote, Outlook.
Okay, also.
Word ist die unsinnigste Anwendung aller Zeiten.
Das ist bloß was für Leute, die nix halbes und nix ganzes suchen, ja.
Also wenn ich einfach was zum Schrei-,
wenn ich einfach nur was schreiben will und leserlich formatieren,
dann mach ich das mit nem Text-Editor in Markdown.
Und wenn ich, ähm, kompliziertes Layout machen will,
dann mach ich das mit irgendeinem Layout-Programm oder Latex.
Latex.
Word ist halt nur für die Oma gut, die mal Geburtstagseinladung machen will.
Need help.
Yes.
Thank you for contacting Microsoft, Agent.
Moment.
Der ist ja wirklich am Start.
Piss dich alle.
Geh weg.
Lul.
Ich hab jetzt eigentlich gedacht, das ist eher so, eher so ein Fake-Chat.
Also, ähm, Word, komplett sinnlos.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Ähm.
PowerPoint.
Auch komplett sinnlos.
Brauchen wir nicht.
Das brauchen nur irgendwelche Leute, irgendwelche Business-Leute, die PowerPoint-Präsentationen
machen wollen.
Es gibt genug andere Möglichkeiten, gute Präsentationen zu machen ohne PowerPoint.
Gibt mittlerweile auch zig, äh, Markdown-Präsentation-Tools.
Oder ansonsten, wisst ihr, was ich persönlich auch mag?
Einfach PDF.
Weil ich mein, es geht, die ganz-, die ganzen Sachen, die du in PowerPoint machen kannst,
lenken dich ja in der Regel eigentlich nur von der Präsentation ab.
Also, du brauchst nichts, was großartig einfadet an Schrift oder sonst was.
Ich mag, ähm, einfach entweder die Sachen, die Sachen auch in Markdown machen oder eben
halt einfach als PDF.
Da machst du einen PDF-Reader in Fullscreen, machst einfach Seite weiter, Seite zurück.
Also, überhaupt kein Ding.
PowerPoint hab ich, glaub ich, gefühlt seit zehn Jahren nicht mehr oft gehabt.
Ähm.
OneNote ist ganz okay.
Da sieht man schon mal, wie verzweifelt die sind.
Das ist mittlerweile in Ordnung.
Aber, ähm.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das mittlerweile in Office dabei ist.
Früher hatten sie noch diesen Bullshit wie Access und sowas.
Das ist-, gibt's ja-, gibt's-, gibt's anscheinend gar nicht mehr, so wie's aussieht.
Oder gibt's das noch?
Oh je.
Wir bleiben ja auch vor nix verschont.
Wir bleiben-, oh, wir bleiben ja auch echt vor nix, äh, nix verschont, äh.
Da gibt's Publisher.
Das ist ins-, oh, das ist Brechreiz, äh, Publisher.
Das ist auch so eine Software, wo ich nicht weiß, wozu man die braucht.
Ich weiß ja den Chat überhaupt nicht.
Ich lese eigentlich die ganze Zeit den Chat.
Ähm.
So.
Und Access braucht eigentlich auch kein Mensch.
Hat sich eher nach Kacken angehört.
Kannste dir aussuchen.
Was soll denn Publisher sein?
Ich glaub, das ist die-, ich glaube, das ist die-, diese, diese-, dieser Versuch von Microsoft,
so nen-, so nen Layout-Programm zu machen.
Es ist-, es ist Kacke.
Ich hab's vor Jahren irgendwo mal für irgendwas verwendet.
Ja.
Guck, es ist so ein Layout-Programm von Microsoft.
Es ist wirklich, es-, ich, ich weiß gar nicht, wofür man das überhaupt verwenden sollte,
ehrlich gesagt.
Das ist quasi für die Leute, die-, die aus Word rausgelevelt sind oder so.
Ich weiß nicht, wozu.
Also.
Für'n Arsch, für'n Arsch, für'n Arsch, für'n Arsch.
Bleiben noch zwei Sachen übrig, Excel und Outlook.
Outlook prinzipiell auch für'n Arsch.
Es sei denn, man steht auf, ähm, Exchange.
Und möchte den ganzen Scheiß drumherum verwenden.
Ja, also von Terminen bis zu Mobile Clients und Gedöns.
Dann vielleicht, ansonsten das einzig-, das einzige Programm, was irgendwie ne Daseinsberechtigung
hat, ist Excel.
Und selbst das braucht man eigentlich nicht wirklich.
Äh, ich weiß nicht.
Und das hier schreckt mich, also das-, das hier enthaltene Dienst des Skype erschreckt
mich ja noch mehr ab.
Wir-, wir-, wir jebaiten Microsoft jetzt.
Achtung, wir warten, wir warten jetzt, bis der Kontakt was schreibt.
Mit Kyle, mit Kyle chatten wir und bam.
Ja.
Jebaited Kyle.
Mal gucken, wie oft-, mal gucken, wie oft wir Kyle anschreiben können.
Ja.
Oh, da ist Kyle ja wieder.
Oh, Kyle-, Kyle ist hartnäckig.
Ich will Kyle nicht mehr.
Oder ist es Kylie?
Bäh.
Okay.
Der-, der geht nicht mehr weg.
Ich mach den Browser lieber zu, wer weiß, was noch hier passiert.
Das ist ein Bot, klar ist das ein Bot.
Das ist genauso wie die ganzen Calls einer Mitarbeiterin, was, was, was laut Bildern immer
hübsche Frauen sind.
Immer, ne?
Immer, wenn du auf irgendeiner-, auf irgendeiner Internetseite Support-, Support-Hotline siehst,
dann sind da immer, immer, ähm, immer so, immer, immer Bilder von irgendwelchen jungen
hübschen Mädels.
Support-Hotline, ja?
Was halt...
Du wirst sie komplett, ähm...
Äh...
Ich hab, ich hab vor Jahren mal einen Artikel gelesen, wie man sowas nennt.
Der hat es Happy Talk genannt.
So nach dem Motto, man ist immer halt ultra glücklich auf Werbefotos.
Das sind keine jungen hübschen Mädchen, ne?
Vielleicht sind es auch, vielleicht sind es auch alte Mädels.
Ja, kann ja auch sein.
Aber ich vermute mal, hier zum größten, da sind gar keine Mädels bei der Hotline.
Also zumindest nicht zu 95 Prozent, wie das die Bilder einem weismachen wollen.
Am besten ist eh immer noch indischer Support.
Hallo?
Mein Name ist Peter.
Weil der Inder auch Peter heißt.
Nicht Peter.
So, wo sind wir denn stehen geblieben?
Wir haben noch eine halbe Stunde Zeit für Proggas.
Ich meine, der sieht immer noch ziemlich armselig aus.
Ah, wir haben V-Sync an.
V-Sync an.
Wir gucken jetzt mal unsere CPU-Last an.
V-Sync?
Ah, guck mal, wir haben, wir haben, wir brauchen keine CPU mehr.
V-Sync regelt.
Ah, ja, ja.
Ähm...
Das ist ganz dünn, ich würde mal sagen so 1-2 Pixel oder sowas.
Einen Rahmen und eine Titelleiste.
Und ihr seht schon, ich habe hier so ein bisschen Offset von meinem Rahmen, den ich gemalt habe.
Und das liegt daran, dass selbst wenn ich das Fenster transparent mache,
dass der Rahmen zwar nicht mehr da ist, aber abgezogen wird von meiner Client-Area, wo ich drinnen selber malen kann.
Und das bedeutet, dass ich alles mit einem Offset von 20 Pixel links und 40 Pixel oben malen muss.
Weil oben, weil Titelleiste halt größer ist.
So, und deswegen habe ich das so gemacht.
Und das ist richtig nice hier.
Ich suche mir quasi raus, die Koordinaten zum Monitor, relativ zum Monitor gesehen,
von meinem Fenster, äußere Ecken.
Und dann ziehe ich davon ab, oben Abstand zu Bildschirm,
minus Abstand von meinem inneren Client-Bereich.
Und dann kriege ich raus, wie viel weiter oben ich anfangen muss, nach unten zu malen.
Und wie viel weiter von links nach rechts.
Wie viel weiter von rechts ich anfangen zu malen muss.
Dass ich quasi beim ersten Pixel lande, den man sehen kann.
Und dann setze ich eine Transform-Matrix.
Das ist auch was für alle, die ein bisschen Gui-Framework-Geschichten benutzen oder ein bisschen 3D-Kram machen.
Also es kommt dann relativ oft, dass man sowas braucht.
Und ich sage hier einfach Translation.
Also sprich, alle Aktionen, die ich hier mit meinem Painter, also da, wo ich dann letztendlich die Bilder male,
alle Aktionen, die ich ausführe und Koordinaten dabei angebe,
was ich im Endeffekt bei ganz vielen Sachen,
die sind automatisch schon verschoben um diesen Offset.
Das heißt, Koordinate 0,0 ist logisch gesehen für meinen Painter 0,0.
Auf dem Hintergrund ist es allerdings wirklich Offset Y und Offset X.
Ich hoffe, man hat das jetzt verstanden.
Windows-Style WS-Pop aber, das kann ich mal ausprobieren.
Das ist eine gute Idee.
Probieren wir mal aus.
Ne, Moment.
Welche Programmiersprache ist das?
Ist das C-Sharp?
Das Web-Frontend ist in Vue.js und das Server-Backend ist ASP.NET Core.
Gucken wir mal, was passiert, wenn wir das so setzen.
Ach, come on, Microsoft.
WinForms ist zu alt.
Das erlaubt als Parameter, das nicht zu setzen.
Gott, ist das euer Ernst jetzt oder was?
Cast nach Int kann ich nicht, weil es zu groß ist.
Aber ich kann bestimmt, ich kann bestimmt hier drinnen setzen, Border, Border-Style, Tool-Window oder irgendwie sowas.
Gucken wir mal mein Offset, ob ich den jetzt noch brauche.
Aber das ist auf jeden Fall ein guter Hinweis, dass das eine bessere Idee ist.
Ne, ist immer noch das gleiche, 31.8.
Was kann ich da denn noch für Dinge hinschreiben?
31.8, ändert sich überhaupt nichts dran.
Tja, nein.
Jetzt sollte sich auch was dran ändern.
Ja, jetzt ist 0.0.
Das ist natürlich nice.
Jetzt ist 0.0.
Ja, das ist auch gut.
So kann man das auch machen.
Oder ich mache mein Offset-Gestellte, das geht natürlich auch.
Ne, das L ist, dass das der richtige Typ ist.
Warum heißt der Painter immer noch nicht Bob Ross?
Das ist eigentlich eine geile Idee.
Das ist eigentlich eine lustige Idee.
Also, die richtige DirectX-Bezeichnung ist glaube ich Context, ja.
Aber bei Qt heißt das immer Painter.
Aber Bob Ross finde ich auch nice.
Jetzt malt Bob Ross.
Jetzt wird das von Bob Ross gedraht.
Unter Buchhalter konnte der indische Support helfen.
Skypasser habe ich selbst verwendet, ja das stimmt.
Skype war ja auch mal eine Zeit lang gar nicht so kacke.
Aber mittlerweile ist Skype ganz, ganz räudig geworden.
Ich weiß auch nicht, wie man es so verkacken kann.
Aber man muss auch sagen, Discord ist halt für das meiste echt die bessere Alternative.
Discord ist die einzige
Node.js, Elektron, Chromium-Gedöns-Anwendung, die ich gerne verwende.
Und das wahrscheinlich auch nur,
weil sie performance-kritische Sachen als Node.js C-Plugin dabei hat.
Slack...
Ah, wobei, Slack ist okay.
Aber Slack ist auch so ein Elektron-Node.js-Geschwubbel.
Slack ist okay.
Ich weiß...
Was ich gar nicht so genau verstehe, ist, warum sich Slack eigentlich durchgesetzt hat.
Ich meine,
in den Chat konnte man sich mit Jammer seit Jahren schon...
oder noch früher mit IRC
konnte man sich da einen ordentlichen Chatraum aufmachen.
Und, ähm...
Labern.
Ich weiß, bei Slack gibt es ja noch irgendwelche Sachen, die ich nicht so gut verstehe.
Wir müssen das Resizen, müssen wir auch richtig hinkriegen, das, ähm, komische Geräusche im Skype, ja, das war, das Video kann ich mich noch erinnern.
Ich würde, ich würde gerne irgendwie den, das, das, ich würde gerne das Bild scalen lassen irgendwie.
Also das Bild scaled ja, aber ich würde es, ich würde es gerne in die Mitte, wisst ihr, so in die Mitte scalen lassen, wobei eigentlich braucht man das nicht.
Ist eigentlich komplett sinnlos.
Wie macht man eigentlich ordentliches Drag'n'Drop jetzt mit, ähm, Windows Forms nochmal?
Hab ich schon ewig nicht mehr gemacht.
Mal kurz gucken.
Ah.
Was? Da brauch ich kein Interop für, um eine Borderless Form zu moven.
Schwachsinn.
Das, was ist mit denen los, ey?
Ich kann doch garantiert...
Ich mein, die einfachste Variante wäre...
Ähm, wäre, wenn ich sag, ähm, onMouseDown, weiß jetzt nicht, da gibt's aber bestimmt ne schönere Variante, ja, onMouseDown, so, und dann mach ich einfach bisMouseUp, folge meinem Mauszeiger.
Das wäre die billigste Variante, aber das geht bestimmt schöner.
Was gibt's denn für Drag-Events?
OnTrackDrop, OnTrackEnter, OnTrackLevel.
Nee, nee, nee, Buchhalter, ich hab das schon gesehen.
Ich hab bloß, äh, Chat nicht, äh, gerade so genau angeguckt.
TCP-Port-Sharing-Error, der nur bei wenigen Kunden auftritt.
WCF, oh, oh, das, das ist aber...
Oh mein, nee, ist das überhaupt das Richtige?
Ist das, ist WCF nicht diese, diese, diese Communication, äh, XML-Communication-Gedöns?
Oder verwechsel ich das jetzt?
Das, das ist eklig zu verwenden.
Ja, doch, ich glaub, das ist dieses XML-Zeug.
Dieses, dieses uralte XML, ähm, Communication-Dings, ja, das, wo ich schon damals nicht genau gecheckt hab, wofür man es verwendet.
Und heute wahrscheinlich keiner mehr verwenden will.
Bin nur wegen den Microsoft-Trolls hier.
Na, wirklich, haben wir ja nix gemacht, wir haben den Chat ein paar Mal zugemacht.
Äh, wie move ich denn ordentlich den Windows Forms Window?
So.
Drag.
Window.
Klick.
Gibt's doch bestimmt irgendeine schöne Lösung, dass wir das nicht komplett von Hand bauen müssen.
Die, die machen ernsthaft, das ist doch, hä, was ist denn das?
Warum machen die das alles mit irgendeinem, das geht doch bestimmt schöner.
Kennt hier jemand eine schöne Möglichkeit, in einer WPF-Anwendung Bilder von einem externen USB-Gerät zum Beispiel zum Handy zu importieren?
Also ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass es eine Library gibt für exakt...
...diesen Zweck.
Ich geh mal davon aus, du musst ein paar Sachen verbinden.
Was ist denn scheiß wirklich von Hand machen, oder?
Man kann, man konnte doch irgendwie...
...muss mal probieren, versuchen, ob ich das Fenster moven kann.
Ja, 800.
So, jetzt sollte sich, jetzt sollte sich das ja eigentlich bewegen, das Fenster, wenn ich reinklicke.
Macht's auch.
Ja, easy, dann ist, dann ist das da überhaupt kein Ding.
Na, machen wir irgendwie sowas wie...
Das geht bestimmt schöner.
Ja, äh, track.
Tracking oder so.
What?
Äh, left.
Äh, button.
Gleich, gleich, left.
So, und jetzt, äh, moven wir das Fenster einfach...
...einfach mit der Maus.
Aber das geht bestimmt schöner.
Maus, move.
Aber das kann doch nicht sein, dass man das wirklich so komplett von Hand track-and-drop basteln muss.
Was, registry?
What?
Was los, chat, registry?
Geht mal fort.
Ach, die Windows-Registry, sowas ist...
Die Registry ist tatsächlich sowas, sowas von MonkaS.
Am besten finde ich ja die Gerüchte um die, um die Registry, ne?
So nach dem Motto, du musst deine Registry defragmentieren und sowas.
Was das überhaupt sein soll, keine Ahnung, kann dir keiner sagen.
Oder, du musst deine Registry...
äh, cleanen lassen, oder du musst dein Windows neu installieren, weil die Registry vollmüllt und sowas, pfff, aller Blödsinn, äh.
Am besten sind die, am besten sind diese Hacks, diese Tricks, so nach dem Motto, setze diesen Key in der Registry, der angeblich, wenn du nachguckst, seit 890, Windows 890, nicht mehr ausgelesen wird, ja?
Registry ist echt so ein Mysterium, ja, da gebe ich, gebe ich dir recht, äh, Mary, allerdings, äh, ist es vieles unter Windows.
Übelste Marke.
Ich meine, guck dir mal das hier an.
Ich meine, ich, ich, ich hab, ich hab's extra, ich hab, ich hab das, die Methode extra schon Setup Windows Magic genannt, ja?
Also wenn du mir das mal irgendwann erklären kannst, was es macht, dass es funktioniert, weiß ich, dann, da wär ich, würd ich mich freuen.
So, Maus, Event Arcs.
X, wir machen das jetzt mal ganz, ganz simpel.
This, X.
Äh, Left.
Also volle Idee, müsste doch jetzt...
Ach so, äh, if...
Tracking.
Also, ich weiß gar nicht, warum das Deck Overflow irgendwas erzählt.
Äh, es geht über der Maus.
Ah, ich weiß, weiß, woran's liegt.
Ja!
Geh weg.
Äh, ich, ich sollte mit meiner Maus auch im Fenster bleiben.
15 Minuten bis 22 Uhr, ja, leider, leider, leider.
Ich will ja im Fenster bleiben.
Hier, plus 20 oder so.
Oder auch nicht.
Irgendwas, irgendwas verkacke ich gerade von der Logik, äh.
Ich will einfach nur gucken, ob's prinzipiell funktioniert.
Aber ich meine, das Fenster bewegt sich, das passt.
Minus 20.
Abziehen.
Ja, ich muss das erstmal in Screen Coordinates umrechnen oder sowas, aber...
Ah, nee, hier, Location haben wir doch.
Offset.
Ach nee, ich weiß, woran das liegt.
Ähm, das spackt rum, weil das Fenster springt da hin und dann ist das nächste Maus Move Event am Start.
Das muss doch ein bisschen anders sein.
Aber prinzipiell funktioniert das doch so.
Warum sollte ich da irgendwelche Windows-API-Geschichten basteln?
Ja, das müsste ich, müsste, äh, Terafox muss ich mir doch mal überlegen.
Aber im Prinzip müsste das doch so funktionieren.
Dass das einfach Fenster dahin springt, wo die Maus ist.
Deswegen jumpt es auch so hin und her.
Weil das Event an ganz vielen unterschiedlichen Stellen dann kommt, aber...
Ah, ich müsste jetzt quasi gucken, wo ist die Maus in Screen Coordinates oder sowas.
Ah, ich müsste jetzt...
Also irgendwie sowas hier gucken.
Irgendwie so, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wie, wie, wie, wie translatet man Points nochmal?
Point.
Point to Client.
Genau.
Location.
Äh.
Ah, das ist nicht so ganz richtig.
What?
Nee, Moment, das ist schon die Location, das...
Moment.
Es ist schon die Location zum Client.
Das ist gar nicht die Location zum Screen, oder?
Ja.
Ah.
Der F, das ist schon die, die...
Das heißt, ich muss es umgedreht machen.
Ich muss Point, Point to Screen machen.
Point to Screen.
Mal erstmal so mal probieren.
Ja, guckt.
Geht doch.
Easy Window Move.
On.
Maus.
Da krieg ich hier keinen IntelliSense da.
Gibt sich sowas wie On Maus, äh...
Maus Button oder sowas.
Maus Capture.
Ja, das sollten wir machen.
Maus sollten wir Capturen.
Maus Up.
Also das ist jetzt so die ganz, ganz billige, schnelle Variante,
wie wir ein ordentliches Track & Drop von der Form machen können.
Äh.
Ja.
Funziert auch prinzipiell.
Das Ganze können wir jetzt mal nach oben und unten machen.
Wir müssen uns unsere...
Unsere Screen...
Unsere Screen-Koordinats merken, wo wir sind.
Also wir müssen das abziehen davon.
Wir wollen ja nicht immer an den linken Rand springen zum Track & Dropen vorm Fenster.
Aber warum die auf Stack Overflow irgendwas erzählt hätten von
man muss da mit Native Windows Zeugs rumhantieren, weiß ich nicht.
Achso, die Maus sollten wir noch Capturen.
Ja, das sollten wir machen.
Ähm...
Capture Maus.
Kann ich das Capture True?
Geht das so?
Ist die Maus dann...
Ah, Moment.
Moment.
Vorher machen wir auf jeden Fall mehr Capture Falls.
Okay, das Capture die Maus gar nicht.
Informs.
Capture Maus.
Wie geht das?
Englisch.
Hä?
Also mit Capture Maus meinte ich eigentlich, dass die Maus dann verschwindet, ne?
Wobei, das macht Windows ja anscheinend nicht.
Anscheinend ist Windows äh...
Capture die Maus ja gar nicht.
Naja, dann lassen wir das.
Kann ich davon jetzt irgendwie...
X abziehen oder ergibt das keinen Sinn?
Oh, woho.
Hahaha.
Gut.
Okay, ne, das ergibt keinen Sinn.
Das ergibt keinen Sinn, was ich da mache.
Haha.
Ich muss jetzt eigentlich...
Ach ne, Moment.
Ich muss davon...
Ich...
Wir sind jetzt...
Wir sind jetzt an der linken...
Wir sind jetzt hier an der linken...
Wir setzen das Fenster jetzt auf die linke Ecke.
Von der Klickposition.
Das wollen wir ja gar nicht.
Wir wollen es nicht aufnehmen.
Okay.
Auf die Klickposition setzen.
Sondern wir wollen es quasi links daneber setzen.
Und zwar so viel Pixel, wie der Mauszeiger vom Bildschirmrand...
Ent...
Falsche Richtung.
So viel, wie der Mauszeiger von der Mitte entfernt ist.
Also quasi minus...
Äh...
Also...
Die...
Boah, jetzt...
Hm.
Ich will davon eigentlich abziehen.
Ah.
363.
Wieso?
Das passt doch.
Aber die nächsten Moves passt nicht mehr.
Ah, verstehe.
Das war doch eigentlich...
Eigentlich war das doch gar nicht so verkehrt, was ich da gemacht habe, oder?
Ich meine, von der Logik her...
In X...
In X steht doch...
Wenn ich...
Also...
In X steht doch, wie weit ich entfernt bin vom linken Rand von meinem Fenster, oder?
Aber das funktioniert nicht.
Das ist...
Ähm...
Warte mal.
Ich glaube, ich muss das...
Muss ich das hier noch translaten?
Nochmal?
Nee.
Hä?
Ah!
Da muss ich mir mal in Ruhe Gedanken kümmern.
Es ist leider schon 22 Uhr, aber wir könnten...
Wir könnten eine Sache noch machen.
Wir könnten hier...
Mal gucken, was passiert, wenn wir Location setzen, auf Target.
Gut.
auf tage gibt dann müsste zumindest die y-achse auch noch mitmachen
genau zwar nur die linke obere ecke es funktioniert schon mal
man darf davon kann man darf davon bestimmt nicht abziehen
ja das funktioniert doch prinzipiell sagen warum warum genau geht jetzt die
location nicht wird gibt es nicht so ein funktionieren
naja probiere ich da noch ein bisschen rum ich muss jetzt leider penne ob ich
irgendwas überlesen haben auch im chat und von der idee würde ich sagen ich
müsste eigentlich eigentlich sinnvoll ja wenn das wird nicht funktionieren das
ist
aber das andere
muss ich mal nachschauen wie man das ordentlich machen aber ich bin da echt
jetzt langsam zufrieden mit wenn wir das jetzt noch hinkriegen dass damit einfach
schön dass wir schön re-sizen können das war schön das ist kein
großartiges ding also wir haben dann später kein fensterrahmen mehr drauf wir
haben nur unseren eigenen rahmen dass wir hin und her schieben können was wir
teilweise schon können dass wir ordentlich re-sizen können dann haben
wir quasi die funktion das wpf fenster hatte nachgebaut was wir dann noch
machen müssen oder das können wir uns überlegen ob wir normale bilder auch mit
ffm pack anzeigen oder ob ich einfach nun sehen wie anders noch ein bauer aber ich
meine guck mal wie simpel es war im endeffekt einen gif animieren zu
animieren mit ffm pack da kann man den png auch ohne probleme anzeigen lassen
da müssen wir halt noch im zweifelsfall pixel konvertieren lassen in in in bgaa
format so habe ich irgendwas übersehen hey max magst du vielleicht mal über
meine pc zusammenstellung gucken bist du noch da das könnten wir jetzt
eigentlich abschließend machen ich muss aber gleich dazu sagen ich habe
jetzt dann wieder nicht so extrem auf dem laufenden aber schick mal können wir
uns angucken wenn du willst stimmt richtig
joke gaming hat recht wir müssen das nicht jedes mal machen wir müssen uns den initialen
wir müssen uns merken die koordinaten wo wir angefangen haben zu klicken weil
danach stimmt es ja nicht mehr beim nächsten event und da müssen wir das da
einfach dazu rechnen ja dass das geht glaube ich ganz gut
so ich glaube jetzt habe ich nichts mehr übersehen
da rechner zusammenstellung das kann man jetzt aber machen kommen wir gucken uns
aber kurz die rechner zusammenstellung von flame hays an vermute mal dass es
nicht flame hat sie ist
das ist hays wieder das ist quasi der hays zum faceclan das ist quasi die deutschsprachige
faceclan konkurrenz irgendwie geht der link nicht der link ist falsch das muss
bestimmt lulz heißen hinten oder nein muss es auch nicht schick nochmal vielleicht ist
deine liste auch nicht öffentlich wie gesagt ich gehe davon aus die liste ist
nicht geshared
ja das kenne ich schon ich kenne auch das video davon wo das irgendein typ sich zehn stunden anschaut das ist ganz verrückt der ist kurz vorm verrecken der typ danach jetzt stimmt's okay
also ein neuer pc
für den flame haze
kosten insgesamt
geb nicht dabei möchte amazon wahrscheinlich nicht dass man das
also wenn eine kompetente auskunft haben willst werde ich noch mal da in irgendeine vorraum Ukrainian computer base oder so
oder irgendwie keine ahnung bei rampen oder soocalyptic
antwerb
wo ein dass ich damit ausschaut
ja man ganz circular
2024 vielleicht schlecht
Ich glaube, die gleiche habe ich auch bloß in der M2-Variante.
Da machst du nicht allzu viel verkehrt.
Moment, warum denn zweimal?
Was hältst du denn davon, die M2-SSD wegzulassen und dir eine größere SATA-SSD zu holen für den gleichen Preis?
Was sagst du dazu? Kohle gespart.
Sparst du quasi 80 Euro?
Ich gehe mal davon aus, du hast zwei, weil dir die M2 zu klein ist.
Und die 1TB zu teuer.
Also hier würde ich die... Achso, wolltest du auch schon.
Ja, also hier würde ich auf jeden Fall die 1TB nehmen.
Ich habe ja vor Jahren mal in den sauren Apfel gebissen, als SSTs noch teuer waren.
Also ja, doch, ist wirklich schon Jahre her.
Und habe mir eine 2TB damals gekauft.
Und die hat damals, glaube ich, 60€.
600€ gekostet oder so.
2TB SSD.
Ich muss gerade mal... Ich gucke gerade mal auf dem zweiten Rechner nach, wie teuer der Krams war.
Und lass ich mal gucken, wie sehr sich das vergünstigt hat.
SSD, SSD, Samsung.
2TB, ja hier.
2015 habe ich mir die gekauft, 2TB.
Alter, 689€ habe ich damals für bezahlt.
Ne, sogar noch mehr.
700€ habe ich bezahlt für die SSD damals.
Krasser Scheiß, ja.
Und jetzt kostet sie die Hälfte.
Das war der Vorgänger von der.
Was, Postleitzahl-Leak?
Wo ist eine Postleitzahl geleakt?
Ach da.
Ne, stimmt nicht, ganz ist aber in der Nähe.
Man hat es doch schon mal gesehen, dass das in meinen Teil liegt.
Das ist doch schon geleakt.
Und wenn ihr wisst, wo der Bahnhof in meinen Teil ist, ist es auch nicht so weit weg.
So.
Be quiet. Die Dinger sind immer ganz gut.
750W weiß ich nicht, ob du es brauchst.
Das könnte natürlich überdimensioniert sein.
Kommt auf den Rest an.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auch.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auch drin, oder?
Kann das sein?
Ne, nicht der.
Der auch nicht.
Da.
Einmal rechnen, so findet man es, okay.
So, warte. Hatte ich nicht das gleiche Netzteil drinne?
Doch.
Aber ich habe die 650-Variante.
Das heißt, du wirst wahrscheinlich auch keine 750-Variante brauchen.
So, gucken wir mal, was da sonst noch drinne ist.
Gut, Gehäuse halt, wie es einem gefällt.
Asus ROG Strix.
Dazu kann ich nicht wirklich was sagen.
Es ist ein Board für einen AMD-Chip.
So viel erkenne ich.
Boards kenne ich mich nicht aus.
Das liegt einfach daran, ich weiß nicht, auf was man da aktuell gucken muss.
Es sieht auf jeden Fall abgedreht aus.
Was sind denn die Vorteile von dem Board?
Was haben die denn hier so schönes zu bieten?
Was haben sie denn da so drauf?
Was zeichnet das dann aus?
Gaming, Audio, das Zeug braucht man einen Einschnitt.
Was?
Jetzt fangen wir schon an mit M2-Lüfter, oder was?
Das wird ja bloß noch vom Asus-Monitor getoppt, der einen Lüfter eingebaut hat.
Ja ok, Mainboard kann ich nicht sagen, aber so lange die CPU passt, ok.
Vielleicht gibt es da günstigere Alternativen, kann ich nichts zu sagen.
Da hast du gut was vor.
Alter, da hast du echt aber was vor.
Preis-Leistung ist das natürlich nicht, der Wahnsinn, aber haut rein.
Wie gesagt, ich habe ja schon eine ganze Weile die 1080Ti drinne.
Und, übrigens Nvidia ich mach jetzt auch demnächst wieder mehr Videos.
Ihr könnt mir ruhig doch noch die Grafikkarte schicken wieder.
Nur so angemerkt.
Falls das irgendwie einer affairiert
Also nehm ich gerne.
Und mach auch was!
Und wenn man davon ausgeht die 280Ti ist mal wieder die üblichen fünfundzwanzig Prozent schneller.
Dann ist das Ding auf jeden fall ordentlich wumms...
Aber ich muss ehrlich sagen
Die Preise von Grafikkarten sind jenseits von gut 100 und über die grate dice auch mittlerweile inmarc durch.
jenseits von gut und böse früher hast du für 800 euro bezahlt ja also nvidia nutzer schon
gnadenlos aus dass am die im absoluten high end segment nichts zu bieten hat mal cpu sieht man
ja auch dass es was bringt wenn er noch ein zweiter mit am start ist nvidia kann es halt
hier aktuell machen wie sie lustig sind und 1500 euro für das high end modell ist eigentlich ein
schlechter witz wenn du überlegst für den preis hast du dich früher die taten quasi die für die
taten geholt das war jetzt das ist ja noch mal eins drüber und jetzt kostet es normale
high end modell 1500 das ist schon weiß nicht aber es ist auf jeden fall bestimmt eine nice
grafikkarte corsair vengeance dings zweimal 16 g war kann man bestimmt nicht viel falsch
machen mit du musst immer gucken dass er unter lüfter passen bei diesen komischen kühl retten
rams was was ist die blue von md war das nicht für video überwachung
kann man machen musst du wissen wie viele da brauchst so und jetzt kommt natürlich die
breite den rützen 2007 oder xl das ding ist auf jeden fall nice wenn man sich die patch
box 188 kerne ja gerne das ist die neue generation also du hast auf jeden fall genug leistung das ist
das ist klar hast du den extra rützen lüfter oder willst du den box verwenden ist ja überhaupt
einer dabei ist dabei also ich schwöre ja auf ordentliche auf noktura noktura cpu kühler gibt
nichts besseres und leider auch nichts teureres festblatt ist eigentlich fast egal ich habe schon
seit jahren hier mache ich will die green 2 terabyte rumliegen ist besser nichts kaputt
gegangen rgb ist ordentlich und der ram hat kein rgb da da verschenkt der rgb
so eine option das ding hat ordentlich power ja also ich persönlich wenn ich schon wenn ich
schon ne also du kannst jetzt letzt halt kannst du ruhig nur mal kleiner nehmen da brauchst du
keinen also ganz ruhig auch 11 aber das macht's im prinzip auch noch mal aus bei dem bei der kohle
was das ding kostet also ich würde mir noch tour nicht da drauf machen noch weil ich noch tour nix da mag und mir werde so schon T pytet ihr mir gern ein stück und ich defectiere zumindest bei dem der wert und es ist genauso gut like a contribution ich hab davon geträumt und da jetzt rausgegangen und schon verdient ich auch wirklich gut sowie ich meine vielen
cOMANCE ich würde mir eine noktura Núckel управlegendes High Crist Orleans
könnt ihr cprove twitter bitcoin bein machen heute neue boxspiel eingehen man muss frei meint ihr jetzt kommt für euch
weil ich Noctua Lüfter mag.
Und mir werden 2TB als Platte
zu klein. Aber der Rest
ist rund, ja.
Der Rest ist rund. Die Problem ist
aber, also ich würde es mir jetzt nicht einfach so kaufen.
Ich würde nochmal das mit irgendeinem checken,
der sich aktuell
auskennt, weil es gibt immer so ein paar
Fallstricke, die kennt man nur,
wenn man aktuell dabei ist.
2TB
zu klein, klar. Wenn du ein bisschen
Shadowplay aufnimmst und so was und Battlefield-Runde hat
25G.
Ich hab, im NAS hab ich 3x
10TB und
jeweils im Rechner nochmal
einmal 6TB
im anderen auch nochmal 6TB.
Muss.
Wo muss der Scheiß da hin?
Hier muss der Kramer
gespeichert werden, ne?
Wie gesagt, Gameplay-Material ist
ordentlich.
Was sagst du zur 25€
SSD auf Hardware-Rad?
Wird bestimmt was taugen.
Ich glaube nicht, dass er Mist verkauft.
Was ist das für eine?
Bestimmt ne 500...
Ne, ne...
Ha!
Hier heißen die, diese MX
400 irgendwas
Mikron-Dings da.
Keine Ahnung. Gucken wir doch mal.
25€
von Hardware-Rad.
Gucken wir mal. Übrigens,
äh...
Ah, nicht Rate, Rad.
Wo hat er denn die
SSDs? Wo ist denn die
25€ SSD?
Die da?
Ah ja, die Crucial-Dinger meinte ich genau.
Nicht MXBX.
SSDs kannst du dir im Prinzip
äh...
Da kannst du jetzt nicht mehr so viel verkehrt machen eigentlich.
Achso, ne.
Du musst ja nicht
Hardware-Rad quasi
eine E-Mail in seinem Shop schreiben.
Du kannst beispielsweise bei ihm
im Livestream vorbeigucken und fragen,
oder aber du machst
wie viele andere Leute auch,
du fragst mal auf Computerbase.
Also Hardware-Rad hab ich schon gesehen,
der macht, wenn er Livestreams macht,
äh, macht er öfters für irgendwie
kleine Donation, macht er dann auch
Kaufberatung im Stream.
Alternativ kannst du natürlich auch einfach
zu Computerbase gehen oder gehst PC Master Race
Reddit und fragst mal, was sie von deiner
Zusammenstellung halten, weil
ich würd mir auf jeden Fall noch ne Meinung einholen von jemand,
der auf dem aktuellen Stand ist, was so
äh, Unverträglichkeiten an,
anbelangt, ja.
Es gibt ja immer wieder so kleine Sachen, wo man,
wo man einfach nicht drauf achtet, wenn man nicht auf
dem aktuellen Stand ist.
Ja, zum Beispiel war es sehr schwierig, damals
durchzublicken, welche Mainboards jetzt eigentlich,
äh, weil die Sockel-Bezeichnung von
Intel so bescheuert war für den 8700K.
Das war auch schwierig, da
durchzublicken, wenn man nicht auf dem aktuellen Stand war.
Ja, so ein paar Sachen,
oder wie das zum Beispiel, äh,
in das Gehäuse die Grafikkarte nicht reinpasst
von voller Länge.
Zum, es ist alles Beispiele, muss
jetzt hier nicht sein, ja.
Hm.
Oder das, dass bei diesem Mainboard speziell
irgendwie unter diesen Lüftertyp
der RAM nicht mehr passt, oder sowas.
Das können ja bloß Leute sagen, die auf dem aktuellen Stand sind.
Ja, guck mal, ich hab jetzt hier drinnen,
ah, man sieht's
glaube ich gar nicht alles, ne.
Ne, man sieht's gar nicht alles.
Weil die Platten sind alle,
sind alle, äh,
crypted.
Und die werden nur auf meinem anderen Account gemountet.
Sieht man gar nicht.
Man sieht bloß die M2 SSD.
Ok, Leute, ähm,
ich muss jetzt so langsam, aber sicher
pennen. Wir suchen Outromusik.
Wobei, wir hatten, wir hatten
letztens einen coolen Remix davon, der war
sehr nice.
Der da, der war cool. Ok, Leute,
also, wir sehen uns
die Tage, vielleicht schon morgen.
Macht's gut, bis denn.
See you.